hallo mein name ist khan herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video von mir denke ich alle den kanal
von viktor kaplan
so sieht der ganze kanadier aus übrigen
schöner blick hier gerade viktor gästen
echt cooler kanal schaue ich mir gerne
mal an und da bin ich letztes einfach
mal auf die videos gegangen hat mir das
niemals ein bisschen zu gemüte geführt
man die sachen die ich bekomme ein
adoptivsohn ich werde mundtot gemacht
mein problem mit logen paul und unter
anderem halt auch ansage an crafter und
da dachte ich mir
ihr habt mir zahlreiche in den
kommentaren gesagt ich soll auf dieses
video mal reagieren deswegen wir fangen
jetzt erst mal ganz kurz
ich finde viktor hat eines der
simpelsten aber auch neuesten infos die
es überhaupt gibt auf youtube.com viktor
warum hast du das gezeigt jetzt habe ich
und ich fand wir haben über wochen 2800
trotzdem gibt es wieder wie früher
damit wird
das videos vier wochen alt das nicht
jetzt erst hat sich vor ein paar tagen
auf cape reagiert habe meine ich zu euch
schreibt mir mal videos in die
kommentare oder irgendwelche youtube
kanäle auf die ich reagieren soll und da
haben wir voll vielen dieses video unter
gestimmt ich dachte sein neu aber das
ist das ist vom 30
das ist von letztem jahr
ich kriege so was man nicht allzu
schnell mit baby und luca und premium
die youtube deutschland wurde
hauptsache baby und ich streiten uns da
vorne irgendwo und revie streiten sich
mit ganz youtube hier neben haben und
ich hoffe irgendwie dass der trend 2018
ein bisschen absurd
ja und dann kam laugen paul und hat eine
leiche gefilmt bevor ich mir das video
weiter anschauen also ich habe es bisher
noch kein einziges mal gesehen
beef gehört meiner meinung nach
irgendwie so ein bisschen dazu also
natürlich keiner wünscht sich beef aber
es ist immer vorhanden weil leute halt
unterschiedliche meinungen haben kuchen
tv tauchen videos zu dieser baby sache
gemacht zu einem herrn user dazu ein
video gemacht ist respekt hat kennedy
alle haben sich da wie sonst was drauf
gestürzt aber wir schauen uns ja jetzt
das video von abu ali an das würde zu
machen wenn jemand mal die anrufe tun
sollte zu tun
also
jetzt auf den beef oder kommentiert
jetzt kommentare ich kenne das format
als von victor lkw-plane und ich feiern
als person einerseits private mega und
halten auch auf youtube seine videos wie
er das ganze schneidet das ist einfach
mega cool aber hey ich dachte jetzt
kommt eine ansage an mich weil da steht
halt im titel aber wir schauen mal
weiter
ja genau so gut frank anrufe seien hallo
ich habe da die eltern gefangen genommen
ok ich glaube ja kommentiert jetzt hier
wirklich die ganze zeit irgendwelche
kommentare hier sogar noch seinen
kurzfilm immer schauen kommen hier doch
was ist das
da kriegen kinder albträume hat manchmal
habe ich das gefühl ich wäre die
perfekte psychopath für irgendwelche
filme ja wie gesagt okay hier noch
irgendwelche kommentare hier wieder
sinken kurz und dann haben wir 9
kommentare und zwar den kommentaren wie
viele situationen hättest du bereits in
denen bereut ok wieder an andere
kommentare eine ewigkeit später also
schon aber die schreiben und liebt wie
würdest du deine meinung zu dem ganz
diverses con crafter getönt jetzt jetzt
jetzt ad hoc in marl dollar erst ich
habe nichts gegen luca oder baby aber
die andere video vorne erst ich habe
nichts gegen luca oder baby aber die an
solche von luca und wie finde ich
ziemlich unnötig meinte du ja gebe ich
zu war wirklich blöd also allerdings
nicht mitbekommen haben erstmals tut mir
leid dass ich jetzt vier wochen nach der
ganzen aktion also einen monat danach
erst hier raus reagiere aber ich war
viel viel unterwegs und kommen auch
jetzt gerade erst aus berlin wieder und
habe es irgendwie jetzt erst so richtig
mitbekommen dass viktor sich dazu
geäußert hat aber um euch ein bisschen
bezug zu geben ich war im urlaub und
habe ein video aufgenommen die mich auf
die ersten videos von youtube an
reagiert habe unter anderem beliebten re
wie ich selbst mag so unter anderem halt
auch babys beauty palace 50 sekunden auf
ihr video baby hat das video geklemmt
und dadurch gegen alle einnahmen des
videos das über zehn minuten ging an
baby obwohl sie nur 50 sekunden
bestandteil davon war und sie nicht nur
im titel stand das video im 1
die ersten videos von youtube oder
irgendwie so und das war nicht der start
dann video dazu aufgenommen obwohl das
nicht baby direkt war sondern nur irgend
so ein automatisches system das baby
zugeteilt hat allerdings hat bibi den
trecker nicht zurückgezogen weil ich
direkt vor das gebietet hatte das war
ein ganz ganz ganz bestimmtes thema
irgendwie und die ansage von mir war
blöd und alles irgendwie hätte ich mir
sparen können aber jetzt schauen wir mal
was ali ali was viktor hier zu sagen
hatte ich meine du geschmerzt über
content id normale regelung okay ich
beschwere mich nicht über content id ich
selber nutze jahr regelmäßig content id
wenn beispielsweise gegen welche anderen
kanäle videos von mir eins zu eins
runterladen und bei sich auf dem kanal
hochladen dann möchte ich natürlich
daran geld verdienen weil das mein
eigener content ist an dem ich
stundenlang gesessen habe der dort ein
nur kopiert und eingefügt hochgeladen
wird in meinem fall war es so dass unter
zehn prozent meines videos von der
youtube ihren babys beauty palace
gehandelt haben und dann nicht mal nur
das video genommen wurden kopiert wurde
sondern ich habe auf ihr video quasi nur
reagiert und ihre tipps befolgt mehr
oder weniger wie sie irgendwie ihre
haare flechten oder so ja du hast jetzt
ein video und keine kohle verdient weil
ich meine wie viel geld das auf gebieten
wie ein abgang
ich meine es geht nicht primär um das
geld es ging mir um den fakt an sich
dass ein video von mir geklemmt wurde
von bibi obwohl es eigentlich gang und
gäbe ist unter youtube an dass man
untereinander auf die videos reagiert
natürlich wenn ich jetzt ihr video
genommen hätte und bei mir hochgeladen
hätte oder wenn ich wirklich nur auf ihr
video reagiert hätte ich jetzt irgendwo
auch verstehen können aber in dem moment
wo ich meine tweets rausgehauen habe
wusste ich noch nicht dass es von
content id geklemmt wurde also das ist
ja gar nicht bbc gesagt hey das ist mein
video sondern das habe ich es im
nachhinein erfahren und hab es dann in
der ansage auch nochmal erwähnt aber ist
ja egal wir schauen mal weiter welche
zum beispiel youtube parodien mache da
nehme ich auch das originalvideo rheine
mit dieser vergleichbar ist und ich habe
da auch schon irgendwie erwartet das
konnte die mich finanziell irgendwie
auch wenn ich die original videos
vielleicht fünf sekunden eingeblendet
habe ich glaube dir waren es künftig und
ich bin nicht
naja ich habe nicht ihr video 50
sekunden eingeplant ich habe mich 50
sekunden lang mit ihrem video befasst
und ich bin nicht mehr primär auf luca
war jeder macht mal fehler und ich hab
nichts gegen den typen aber ich bin mehr
top leute die absolute hinterfragen nur
weil luca auf der guten seite von
youtube steht und baby auch zu
schlechten hier ein neujahrsvorsatz
lernt zu hinterfragen meinetwegen auch
mich stellt ihr bevor
okay das war es jetzt was er quasi zu
dem thema gesagt hat da bin ich auf
jeden fall auf seiner seite
also ich finde es auch nicht gut das
baby immer so krass negativ dargestellt
wird also ich finde das ist er einfach
nur eine youtube drin ist ja mehr oder
weniger eine von uns die details ihren
content hoch und es ist halt teils sehr
sehr werblicher content und so weiter
und so fort da kann man ja seine meinung
zu haben und ich äußere daher auch oft
meine meinung zu allerdings fand ich
wirklich die situation durch das da
dieser content id claim kamen und dass
der auch nicht zurückgezogen wurde und
so weiter und so fort also das war meine
sache damit und ich muss ehrlich gesagt
zugeben meine ansage war doof kuchen tv
die auseinandergenommen ist mir auch
noch mal aufgefallen
die wirklich direkt eine woche nachdem
ich das hochgeladen habe dachte ich mir
nur so was habe ich dagegen vor einer
woche hochgeladen aber ich wollte
einfach meine
sagen ich war vielleicht noch emotional
ein bisschen geladen deswegen sorry für
die ansage an beauty perez toms geht es
in dem video glaube ich nur noch um
andere kommentare noch ein paar
kurzfilme die er macht hier geht dann
noch ag sind das vielleicht erinnerungen
eines parallelen ich sehe die sie mit
uns verknüpfen wenn wir was wien juckt
auf jeden fall hier noch einige andere
kommentare die er hier beantwortet und
das war's danke für dieses video ali mir
wird es wie gesagt sehr häufig in die
kommentare geschrieben und leute meinte
ewig dort eine ansage an dich gemacht
klagt jetzt so an sage okay der
beleidigte mich jetzt gibt der mich
jetzt krass an aber er meint dass man
nur mehr hinterfragen sollte wo ich
selber auch auf seiner meinung
ich bin auf seiner meinung ja man
freunde merkt man dass ich den letzten
nächten fünf stunden schlaf hatte gerade
aus london und berlin wieder kommen
einmal gar nicht ich wollte das ganze
thema nur noch mal endgültig abschließen
bei der kuchen tv auch vor einigen tagen
dazu noch mal ein video gemacht hatte
und er hat mich auch voll gefragt und ob
ich einen gast bad machen wollte und so
sehr alles cool und so klingt ja gerade
auch gesagt natürlich ist zwischen uns
allen alles okay alles gut wie alles
kader butter und ob zwischen mir und
baby nicht weil ich mit der nichts zu
tun habe aber wenn ihr ideen habt auf
welches video eventuell demnächst
reagieren könnte also irgendwie also
nicht haye luca in italien stopfen sich
neuerdings leute pizzen in den po
dann schreibt mir gerne in die
kommentare und sonst war's das jetzt
auch schon vom heutigen video ich werde
jetzt nach holland fahren weil ein
kollege von mir dort geburtstag feiert
das heißt die niederlande